happily me but the Busboys okay
yeah-ha-ha [ __ ] cow god damn then
they actually spooped me ha ha hey
somewhere dancing for one goddamn
trapping your torque obsession is not
welcome here
tip don't get hit what a great tip
Justin Bieber I don't know what this
meant oh oh god damn it
I know anyway your diagram boy we're
doing fine doing fine to apply to it but
Wow hey we're a secret zone v5 you thief
and your purpose token purpose token
this one oh it is a click rate 5 got it
I'll be oh I'll play your game you
goddamn it poor go ninja well a lot of
pogos and a lot of Poon's this week
Karnowski ah right in the back of the
neck oh come on
you played yo-yo with Moscow ah Jung
Jung Woo oh that last one got me it had
some unfair oh you've bent me in half
boink okay
swoop T Shuang ko why does that keep
happening
oh no no ah [ __ ] well alright that's
cool
ah what am i but that's my head did I
see that wrong but it oh god what a
compromising position that [ __ ] got ha
heon ping whoa ah yes I'll take it
I'm not in as many pieces I was in the
last word oh I thought he killed me just
do it I'll do it I'll do it
[ __ ] that dragon [ __ ] that dragon riding
his dragon blood okay maybe not [ __ ]
that dragon riding its dragon but [ __ ]
that dragon oh so tender a dragon is
mean I gotta somehow Tom how get away
from the dragon hey hey buddy
whoa who you getting jiggly on me oh you
gettin jiggly oh you so angry
ah oh I say good and good oh I got
minced you dragon [ __ ] you dragon [ __ ]
you dragon sack of [ __ ] you're dragging
more like dragging my balls across your
face that's Illinois oh these are some
huge bottles I don't know about this one
yeah okay all right okay all right okay
and why how and why and how and why yeah
oh yeah these are some huge sponsor oh
Jesus ah oh ah ah ah good they I can fly
oh okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
ah ah yes all right good
I think I pooped my helmet out of my
dick but it alright try to stop by say
impossible my left nurse go go fight
what is it freakin Pogo weak huh boy ski
[ __ ] off with you I'm gonna get you
ah right in your goocher right in your
future hope you die again ha ha
zombie king huh take your spear in my
teeth and I'll shove it up your bum ha
Bisky
Manhunter Manhunter oh not a very good
man under if you ask me Oh No
a drunk kid don't drink children
or else.you parent lead I bring
challenge well okay then
whoa that was a little deviously close
hang on ah ah [ __ ] I don't know what
happened but death came quick oh I need
your bomb I don't need your stuff
I don't need your bomb I've got the
winning recipe right here ah it's
getting rid of this awful Pogo and Wow
[ __ ] God cease you can stop any day now
I'd be fine with that
this is impossible Oh ah [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] happened I don't even know the
sewerage okay why is we down in soo
yonder sewer am I supposed to have oh oh
except stepped in [ __ ] now I smell bad
really death but a bad punishment that's
for sure hey okay ah okay alright ah
this is a weird sewer layout but I
understand it that wall seems weak
well I'll bash it with all my
inhibitions that's way it'll be equally
weak this wall seems stronger i need to
find a hammer you mean like my thick
skull or am I gonna find a hammer are oh
click don't mind if I do
okay so I got a hammer are what is that
gonna do from I'm gonna get you I'll get
you fat broke you're just like all of my
willpower when my wife left me ah I
should have had my helmet [ __ ] fall
ranks
and here we go
ah here we go here we go
oh here we go yeah poon run epic now I
don't know how a pic mostly role of the
different boons well I survived left
okay there's my heart oh no me and my
son just won't live oh god oh god no oh
so fast
obstacle course beige because that's the
most interesting of colors you can't
beat me I'm the gingerbread [ __ ]
I don't know Knight bike club oh this is
actually nice I guess I have a funny
feeling it's gonna end in horrible
horrible ways but for now it's downright
Pleasant old man you're doing such
lovely cartwheels that's amazing oh wow
oh he was just having fun
he was just doing cartwheels and I
killed him and now we've conglomerated
into some horrifying machine of what I
can only assume will be dad's death it's
that oh god its death oh god was I've
drawn that demo oh geez no I don't want
her naked oh okay and one naked
don't jump harpoons lamins if I jump oh
okay ah it was scary
oh hello you've dropped me [ __ ] token oh
boy I'll go for a chest
there in my grundle oh I'm still alive
now we don't go for the token
which is obviously still true don't
forget the token oh wow [ __ ] all right
goddamn it
bottle run okay god damn it ah [ __ ] I
goddamn it when's it gonna end like I'll
god damn it
oh okay final kill him boss [ __ ]
goddamnit where we going down but this
has been happy wheels highlights thanks
for watching if you want to see more
happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye